for season one how many scripts did you
have done
before filming began how was it on
season two and three
how much were you you know figuring out
um one one-liners if you will for each
episode or you know talk a little bit
about
how you figured out the season well i
think you know for the first season
it was it was interesting because we you
know i wrote the pilot
um and there was
a you know it was it was so
uh closely tuned to what thomas harris
uh had written and there was so much
from the books that was going into it
and uh then we had
written i think we had four or five
scripts and then i saw the pilot
and i saw the work that that hugh
and maz were doing and i saw the work
that david slade was doing
and i looked at those four or five
scripts that we had written and i said
that they weren't good enough and i
threw them out
and then we started over but we started
over
in a sense that was you know we i think
we shut down for two weeks between the
pilot and the rest of the
show so after seeing the pilot
and going like what like this is
actually really good and this cast is
phenomenal and they deserve better
material
um because the the four or five scripts
that we had
we had done were very procedural were
very and very sort of strange like one
of the episodes was about a mass
shooting in a mcdonald's
and we were trying to make this
commentary on fast food culture
and gun culture and you know
now looking back on that i'm like what
the [ __ ] were we thinking
because there's no way to skin that and
not be
offensive to somebody um not that i
care about offending people but the
it just was sort of inelegant and cheap
and not necessarily
elevating the genre and i think you know
i i feel a deep responsibility to try to
elevate the
genre of whatever i'm doing um so we
tossed all those scripts out and then it
was a scramble for the rest of the
season and it was really hard on mavs
because
english is his second language and a lot
of the [ __ ] that hannibal is saying
are words that i have to look up to go
like is that right like is that a word
and so i it was it was really difficult
for him
um but we kind of like the first season
was really was
was insane and it was very depressing
and
it felt very much like uh i was in will
graham's head a little too far
uh and i remember there like there was
one time when um
hugh and claire and i were walking
around a park
and it was just like it was just nice to
be
with people who weren't
expecting something from me that i knew
i couldn't give them
and to just have general support and go
like oh like these like i said like
when when you and i had our first dinner
i was like oh
this this is going to be my friend like
this isn't just a working relationship
this is somebody that who's company that
i adore
so like those moments kind of got me
through
the complexities and the real
hardships of season one and then after
surviving something you'll go like oh i
can survive
but season two we got a late pickup
and so our first day in the writers room
without
anything being sort of written or
anything
we were in production six weeks later
and
so they're like there was no catching up
and season two i don't know
hugh if you think season two was worse
than season one in terms of script
delivery
it's hard to say they're so
i mean yeah it's it's it's kind of
really
skinning something but it was it was it
was tough
all along and and yeah that's that's all
i know i mean
in that respect but you know i did i i
worked after hannibal i worked on a show
and
in the first ep season we had all six
six episodes they'd written of 10 i
think we did up front they just had you
know that much time and they had they'd
scripted those six episodes and it was
great i mean it was completely
wild it was almost like a hallucination
for me
um and you know it meant it afforded me
the opportunity to
i guess you know sit with it for longer
obviously
but truthfully in the in the kind of
chaos that that
we experienced and that brian was kind
of in the front line of
uh in retrospect it didn't
kind of compromise for me the the the
kind of ability to
i don't know to to kind of submerge
ourselves in it
and i honestly don't know why that
should be
except for the fact that as i said
before and as it's obvious from what
brian's saying like he
he he and we all
felt that responsibility right not just
not even to anybody else just to
ourselves right who who wants to do
artists that's that's right